[Music]
gotta go fast
20 minutes ago an energy surge knocked
down power across the entire Pacific
Northwest this needs someone who can
figure out exactly what we're deep with
you're not suggest male I think you're
suggesting we have no choice
what are you in charge here yes I know
I'm wrong
mommy charge allow me to clarify in a
sequentially ranked hierarchy based on
level of critical importance the
disparity between us is too vast to
quantify agent stone the doctor thinks
you're basic
listen pal I don't know if you realize
I'm sorry I major what was your name Ben
Joe nobody cares meow
basically it looks like I'm gonna have
to save your planet
[Music]
no but thank you for asking
whatever this creature is our job is to
secure it neutralize it see what makes
it tick
[Music]
look at this I took 9 million steps
today
stay in there to be quiet how much
longer I keep three even here do you
have your child in that Bank no I mean
yes it's a child but it's not Maya it's
not your child
smells like bodies burning an old ham
sandwich
[Music]
you